it's not just travel troubles
threatening the holiday move the cdc
says the average daily number of new
covet cases is surging to more than
176 thousand people that's the highest
it's been in nearly a year nancy chen is
in new york city where cases are
skyrocketing to record numbers nancy
good morning
good morning to you cases are rising
fast here in new york particularly among
children state officials say pediatric
hospitalizations have quadrupled since
early december and schools are also
making changes students here at columbia
university will start next semester
virtually while testing remains a major
challenge across the country
the most popular item this holiday
season a coven 19 test from new york
to los angeles americans spent the
weekend waiting in lines with many
unable to get tested
almost two hours i have a procedure that
needs to be done
proven testing before my procedure and
now they're telling us that they're not
doing it anymore as cases spike in
several states major colleges and
universities like columbia yale and ucla
are planning a virtual start to the next
semester while others like the
university of maryland in northeastern
will resume in-person classes in january
but recommend or mandate booster shots
the virus is also upending college
football the university of miami
withdrew from friday's sun bowl due to
an outbreak on the team while two bowls
scheduled for this week were canceled
because of team withdrawals given the
sheer volume of number of cases that you
see now every day it goes up and up
the last weekly average was about 150
000 and it likely will go
much higher on sunday dr anthony fauci
said while the omicron variant may cause
less severe illness americans must not
let their guards down
we've got to be careful that we don't
get complacent about that because it
might still lead to a lot of
hospitalizations in the united states
when asked about the nation's testing
infrastructure dr fauci admitted it
needed improvement and that those
improvements may not come until january
when the bidet administration plans to
send up to 500 million at home tests to
anyone who wants one need
nancy thank you so much you always give
us the information that we need